it seems to me that
it's very tempting
to
justify our own behavior in investing
they have this this saying eat well or
sleep well that any improvement that you
make to your investing returns that you
make more money generally comes with
more stress
you're making more decisions you're
watching the markets more closely so
there's a real luxury to being hands off
to sleeping well but that luxury comes
at the cost is you're you're probably
not on it as much right you're not is
you're not as on top of things so that's
one of the key trade-offs is like all
right you can't be completely passive
about anything
so any level of being active is going to
bring some level of stress anxiety and
effort
so a lot of the temptation in psychology
we call this status quo bias is hey
everything that i'm doing right now is
pretty great i'm just going to keep on
doing that and i see this a lot when i
lead workshops around a quarterly or
annual review where people's goals tend
to be i'm going to do exactly all the
things that i was just doing plus twenty
percent so all those things i was going
to do i'm going to put up you know 20
more pounds on the bench press i'm going
to write 20 more articles i'm going to
sell 20
more packages and you know
like well okay great like where's that
where all those 20 is going to come from
like what are the things that you're no
longer doing this is like this like same
but more tendency and so a better way
that i think about doing is like i use
another investment analogy imagine that
you sold all of your investments and now
you're just sitting on a pile of cash or
all of your commitments all of your your
job your classes all the things you're
doing you're no longer doing you look at
your calendar and it's completely open
for the next year okay what do you do
with that time
it's like our bias is to justify the
things that we're already doing let's
say okay i'm just going to keep on doing
more than that but it's like realization
you could do anything what do you do
with that i think is a much better place
to operate from because naturally
just to you know
sleep well we tell ourselves hey what
i'm doing is great
but we get all our identity tied up and
like all right if i'm if i'm being
successful then i'm a success if i'm if
i'm doing really well then i'm a good
person like i'm happy all sides of
things versus like
i
am separate from what i do i am not what
i do
given that i am separate what do i
choose to do i think this like this
separation of identity is real important
to be able to take an objective look at
ourselves and say what are the things
that are doing right that i'm doing
right now what are things that are
happening that i think could be going
better what are some things actions that
i could take it doesn't mean that i'm
not doing well i'm doing great but here
are some ways that things be going even
better i think this is a real hack for
objectivity another way is to
imagine that you're giving advice to a
friend
and the friend is in the exact situation
that you're in what's the obvious advice
that you would tell your friend it's
very easy to see from the outside but if
you try to give that advice to
yourselves like well i already tried
that or i can't do that it's like well
what would you tell a friend there's all
of these ways to just be a little bit
more objective about what we're doing
and
this is big for me as i'm always trying
to correct for my natural bias another
one that i like a lot is fear is a
compass so if i'm between two options
always do the thing that's scarier
because naturally i'm gonna shy away
from the thing that i'm afraid of so if
i think i should do it but i'm not sure
and it's really scary then i should
definitely do it
and all this type of stuff is just
coming through
this planning experimentation reflecting
process of like what are the things that
i've learned what how am i going to when
i'm facing this type of decision in the
future you know how do i want to make
this decision as everything that goes
out into eternity i'm thinking about
what's my process going to be how can i
improve this process for the future hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day